hi this is Dr Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason IO
where we put philosophy into
practice I've studied and taught
Philosophy for over 20 years and I find
that many people run into difficulties
reading classic philosophical texts
sometimes it's the way things are said
or how the text is structured but the
concepts themselves are not always that
complicated and that's where I come in
to help students and lifelong Learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to YouTube many
viewers say they find them
useful what you're currently watching is
part of a new series of shorter videos
each of them focused on One Core concept
from an important philosophical text I
hope you find it useful as
well in the third part of his proma to
any future metaphysics Emmanuel Kant is
going to clarify for us the relation
ship between what he calls ideas of
Reason which is largely what this part
of the work is concerned with as is very
important to metaphysics and the
boundaries or
possibilities of experience something
that he has talked quite a lot about and
analyzed in sufficient depth in detail
in the earlier parts and so he tells us
in these General considerations it's
remarkable that the ideas of Reason are
of no service to the use of our
understanding in experience but actually
quite dispensable you don't need them in
order to make sense of the experience
that we have of the world which remember
is not just
perception right van but rather
judgments of experience which bring to
bear the categories or pure concepts of
the understanding that are imposed upon
the intuitions giving us a coherent
experience that we have both exteriorly
of the world and
interiorly as we're going to talk about
so he says that they are actually an
impediment these ideas of reason to the
maxims of a rational cognition of nature
we don't actually need them when we're
doing say pure mathematics which as
we've seen is connected to space and
time or even pure Natural Science but we
are going to need them when it comes to
metaphysics so he says in another
aspects still to be determined they are
necessary we're going to get to that in
just a bit he's going to reinforce the
point by bringing up these three kinds
of ideas of reason as examples so the
psychological idea or ideas he says um
uh whether the soul is or is not a
simple substance is of no consequence to
us in the explanation of its phenomena
notice he's not just saying phenomena in
general but the phenomena of the Soul we
don't actually need to know whether it
is a single simple substance or not with
all the things that t typically go with
substance like you know enduring in time
uh a kind of unity we don't need that in
order to make sense out of our
experiences likewise we don't need the
cosmological ideas Kant is saying and
he's actually saying a little bit more
than uh the text itself self is putting
forward he talks about do we actually
need to know the beginning or The
Eternity of the world in order to make
sense of our experience in the world no
we don't need that it's not helpful it
actually is getting in the way right um
he says these cannot be of any service
to us for the explanation of any event
in the world itself now
interestingly some of the cosmological
ideas you might say well wait a second
Kant you know what about causes and
freedom and K would say in so far as
we're considering the phenomenal you
don't need that that's just going to get
in your way and trip you up now we can
think it and we're going to later
on and then he says you know the
understanding the uh uh nature nature as
the design of nature being drawn from
the will of a Supreme Being he says we
don't actually need this this this gets
in the way as well this would not be
natural philosophy but an admission that
we've come to the end of natural
philosophy now we're doing theology
whether it's natural or philosophical
theology by comparison to actually
studying nature itself we don't need any
of the these ideas psychological
cosmological or uh
theological and so you know he is going
to conclude this by saying the use of
the
ideas is quite different from that of
the categories by which and the
principles built upon which experience
itself first becomes possible so what
the understanding does doesn't need
these ideas of
reason now there's a butt here but our
laborious analytic of the understanding
would be
Superfluous if we had nothing else in
view than the mere cognition of nature
as it can be given in
experience that's an interesting remark
Now isn't it what is the point behind
doing this
analysis of the understanding is it just
to do epistemology in a really basic
sense how do we understand things how do
we grasp things out there in the world
in our experience that's nice but that
isn't its own point or purpose and so we
can ask a deeper question well what is
the use the usefulness the point of
these different ideas of reason is it
that we've got you know well functioning
understanding over here and then we've
got this crazy extra faculty over here
that's just kind of doing its own stuff
and we got to make sure they stay
separate from each
other well K is going to tell us that um
our critique of the understanding
combines with the ideas of pure reason
for a
purpose that lies beyond the empirical
use of the understanding so that holds
out the promise that well you know we've
got our let's call it physics over here
and then we've got our metaphysics over
here understanding and reason and reason
is better it's a higher faculty and so
it's more in tune with you know what we
are as human beings this sounds rather
platonic does it not and Kant is going
to say who nope don't go that way why
not well he says um here we go we have
uh declared the use of the understanding
in this respect to be totally
inadmissible and without any object or
meaning so we we can't effectively drag
the understanding beyond the bounds of
experience
but we do also have to have what he
calls a Harmony
anong right a literally having one voice
you know resonating together would work
well a Harmony between the he calls it
the
nature of reason and the understanding
these two faculties can't just be
separated off from each other each of
them having their own separate domain
they're interconnected with each other
and so he says that the reason must
contribute to the
Perfection of the understanding and it
cannot possibly upset it so he says well
there's a solution to this an aling
right
right so here's here's how Kant proposes
to deal with this uh what is it that
reason actually does so it's going to
require a completeness of fulling kite
something we've seen talked about
earlier in this section each of the
three ideas uh psychological
cosmological and Theological is
involving completeness or
completion um of what it is that
experience
is putting forth I was going to say
providing us with but you know what
experience is is offering but only
partly so reason requires completeness
of the use of the
understanding in the complex the zuus
samung um of of experience so it goes
beyond experience as we saw earlier this
complex of experience is not itself
something that we can experience we can
never experience the completion of the
world we can never experience the
completion of uh our our soul as
substance we can never complete uh
experience the completion of the
totality of the universe as caused by
some intelligent designer or anything
like that so he says that we Um this
completeness can be a completeness of
principles
only
not of um intuitions an shaan or of
objects and here it's very important
Kant is going to use two different terms
that are translated in the English text
by objects
genda the common use for objects
something that literally stands against
us right that we could
encounter and then he'll use the term
object which is a little bit more formal
the cognant of our term object coming
from Latin objectum right so he's going
to uh go on and say that pure reason
right doesn't point to particular
objects that lie beyond the field of
experience but completeness and um this
completeness is of principles princip
right so he says in order to represent
the ideas definitely though reason
conceives them after the fashion of the
cognition of an object object not gagin
right so this is quite important he says
this is as far as these rules reg are
concerned completely determined but the
object is only an idea invented for the
purpose of bringing the cognition of the
understanding as near as possible to the
complete completeness indicated by that
idea so you could say that there there
is an object object for reason but that
object object does not
correspond to an object that is actually
out there a gag andun that could be
encountered uh within the scope of our
experience it's kind of an empty open
you know put whatever cont content you
want in there sort of uh matter and he
goes on a little bit then he's going to
talk about Numa in
this prefatory remark to the dialectic
of of pure reason so he talks about
these pure beings of at first he says
the pure beings of the understanding or
better beings of thought these are in
fact these these ideas and he said says
that they can't find any intuition which
can give them meaning or sense in
concreto they are mere logical functions
they can represent a thing in general
but they cannot themselves uh give a
determinant concept of anything so these
are numina now Kant has already used the
term numina
before in a slightly different sense
where the num are not just beings of
thought but would also signify the the
things in the themselves lying be behind
or beyond the experiential phenomenal
world right here he's saying yeah there
there isn't something that the Numa the
pure you know ideas pure beings of
thought actually correspond to in that
way he calls these hyperbolic objects
and he talks about you know for example
substance but conceived without
permanence in time or cause but not
acting in time predicates that only
serve to make the Conformity to law of
experience possible are applied to these
Concepts and yet they are deprived of
all the conditions of intuition on which
alone experience is possible so these
Concepts lose all significance and then
he talks about this you know
possibility of um the understanding
going going Beyond its range now the
understanding by itself isn't going to
do that
what causes it to do that so he talks
about alien laws where would these alien
laws come
from reason when reason which cannot be
fully satisfied with any empirical use
of the rules of the understanding is
always being conditioned requires a
completion we saw that that is what is
involved in these ideas of reason reason
requires a completeness or completion
when reason requires a completion of
this chain of conditions then the
understanding is forced or we might even
say dragged out of its sphere there is
this close connection you know what he's
called the harmony before that between
reason and the understanding the
understanding would never go wrong if
reason wasn't there in some way to say
hey hey let's go check this out let's go
uh beyond the you know limits of
experience and understanding is like I'm
not sure if I'm supposed to do that and
then reason is like oh come on let's
let's just go see what's up up you know
out there available to us and the
understanding is like well okay I guess
I'll go along with you sort of like a
little brother getting dragged along
into doing the wrong thing by an older
brother who's supposed to be looking
after him right so he goes on and he
says that um reason partly represents
objects of experience in a series so
extended no experience can grasp it it
seeks entirely Beyond experience
numina to which it can attach that chain
and so having at last escaped from these
conditions of experience reason makes
its hold complete k then identifies what
these are these are the transcendental
ideas which may aim not at extravagant
Concepts but at an unbounded extension
of their empirical use but they seduce
the understanding by an unavoidable
illusion to a Transcendent use which
though deceitful cannot be restrained
within the bounds of experience but only
by scientific instruction and with much
difficulty the only thing that can keep
reason from you know
misleading the understanding in this way
is reason carrying out a critical
analysis of
itself in this sort of case which is
what the critique of pure reason is
reason is being applied to reason and
all the other faculties and saying okay
this is legitimate this is not watch out
for this sort of Illusion so this is how
we wind up with these
transcendental ideas that K is now in
the rest of this section going to
analyze further for
us